Donald Trump has made a very important
statement pertaining to very serious
issues here in the United States and
that is he wants us to drink Bud
Light Donald Trump posted the budlight
Ed was a mistake of epic proportions and
for that a very big price was paid but
anheiser bush is not a woke company but
I can give you plenty of that R and
building a list and might just release
it for the world to see why not the
radical left does it viciously to
well-run conservative companies and
people okay I don't understand that very
nasty but it's the way they play the
game on the other Andra Bush spend $700
million a year with our great Farmers
employ 65,000 Americans of which 1,00
are veterans and is a founding corporate
partner of folds of Honor which provides
scholarships for families of Fallen
servicemen and women they have raised
over $30 million and given 44,000
scholarships anheiser bush is a great
American brand that perhaps deserves a
second chance what do you think perhaps
instead we should be going after those
companies that are looking to destroy
America well I will pause there good sir
Donald Trump as much as I'm looking
forward to voting for you you are a far
far from perfect candidate and hezard
Bush is not an American company thank
you and have a nice
day it's a Belgian company it's owned by
inbev right it's not an American company
and I can respect his View and I think
the reason he's doing it is aneis Bush
probably does give a lot of money and so
a lot of politicians are like we need
the money coming from anzer Bush and now
Donald Trump has come out and said it is
time to endend the boycott it's time to
give in to the global fascism what say
you panel
all in favor of ending the budlight
boycott so saith Donald Trump I so don't
even care because I don't drink beer
yeah if if I was in a situation if
someone handed me a beer and it was Bud
Light I would drink it I'm not going to
buy the stuff that's my that's where I'm
at so uh unless I didn't want to drink
it then I wouldn't many people have
responded directly to the post saying no
not until there's an apology and I I I
100% agree I actually so I don't know if
you guys saw the Super Bowl ad they made
it's isn't it really stupid that they're
putting they put Super Bowl ads out
before the Super Bowl now yeah that was
what I was thinking what I think we
broke Bud Light I think we broke them I
think there's like a guy sitting in like
the marketing department his underwear
smoking cigarettes with like bags under
his eyes rocking back and forth I want
to smoke cigarett refreshing his feet
over and over and over yeah just so so
basically they do they they they did
this ad campaign with Miles Teller and
some woman I don't know who she is and
she's on hold and he's like dancing
towards her with two cans of Bud light
and then they dance together and then
laugh and drink Bud Light in the living
room at like 9:00 in the morning or
something I don't know I don't know what
time it's supposed to be in the
commercial but it's stupid anyway
they're both not at work so I'm assuming
it's maybe late but uh it's cringe and
everyone made fun of them for it few
months later they launched the Dylan M
thing and nuked their own company trying
to recover they launched a partnership
with Harley-Davidson we're manly beer we
drive motorcycles and everyone made fun
of them and then I can't remember who it
was uh well they got made fun of then
they partnered with UFC
and uh everyone made fun of them Sean
Strickland came out said I'm going to
fix you and and many people started
saying Hey look it's fine Joe Rogan was
like who cares the beer is fine then
they sponsored Shane Gillis and Shane
Gillis is is not a woke comedian they uh
I don't know what capacity they're
working with him but he got cancelled
for I think he was doing like an Asian
accent and still people are like I don't
know he got canceled for doing an Asian
accent yeah so that's what it was right
it was an Asian it an Asian Accent on a
podcast like
that's he was on satet live and then
someone found an old video of him this
is why this is why it's so clearly like
just it's about an attack Vector because
like the guys in South Park have been
doing Asian accents for the entire time
that they've had shitty walk you know
that's right or City Walk well you know
and so uh budlight made a commercial now
for the Super Bowl and it's the Bud
Light
Genie and it is it is it's it's it's
like someone just just put a bunch of
random words in a Ai and it spat out
it's AI generated commercial I think
they were just like I don't know CH GPT
right a commercial force and they're
like okay a guy opens a fridge and he
grabs a Bud Light then a genie pops out
he wishes for heavy metal hair a woman
wishes for uh wealthy clothing another
guy wishes for one big arm then they
wish to be at a party then post Malone
is there then a T-Rex comes in post
Malone takes credit for it then they
wish everybody has Bud Light and the
genie tries dancing and then they're
like the Bud Light Genie and that then
it's over oh God that sounds horrible
man sounds so bizarre I don't know who
we broke I like post Malone he's cool
but we we I'm like we broke them like
they don't know what to do at all and
they're like post Malone dinosaurs
genies and then and then Donald Trump
the trump card Bud Light somehow got
Donald Trump to post please please drink
Bud Light I hope he at least got got
paid for this then maybe he knows
somebody company or he just saw that cuz
it is care about money anheiser Bush
does have a a factory in the United
States at least one I think the
headquarters it's a subsidiary of a
Belgian company so technically it's
Belgian but it is in trench to the
United States highes Americans and
that's what Trump's concerned with is
those people but that's like a
short-term thing you can't if you always
trying to fix the people around you but
you're not looking at the bigger picture
of what's causing the problem you might
end up just feeding into the greater
problem let's do a poll smash the like
button if you think we should not buy
budlight until they
apologize I'm going smash I know that
like the like button's going to the like
count is going to Skyrocket because
because of that that's kind of the point
but uh I would actually agree my I think
with this move and we've got the
upcoming uh strike that's going to
happen which is going to just decimate
budlight I think that's why Trump they
tapped the big guns they're like Trump
we need you to come out I wonder how
much they've pledged I mean look right
if Donald Trump is coming out defense of
budlight they've basically aligned
themselves more than any company could
align themselves so budlight just
publicly declare you're committing a
billion dollars to Donald Trump's
re-election in some capacity I'll tell
you this how about you run a commercial
apologizing saying anzar Bush loves
America made a terrible mistake and is
deeply apologetic for the the insult and
the offense and then Donald Trump walks
in the frame and says and that's why I
drink Bud Light and cracks One open then
we go buy some it's just like please
accept my apologies so that our Global
corporations can take you over like
no thanks I'm done I I learned my lesson
it's like a bad relationship I'm never
going back I already made my move you
know why doesn't Donald Trump post post
Donald Trump should come out and be like
everyone go by conservative dad's Ultra
right right why don't why aren't we
building the parallel economy up yeah
that's a question I ask myself whenever
uh people are like why are you not
voting for Donald Trump I go come the
questions like why is he not tapped into
what we what's really going on why is he
like still corporate why is he still
playing with the the big money guys and
cuz he's a million cuz he's a
millionaire well so because he's a
million years old here's a question for
everybody listening uh it seems like the
general sentiment response to Trump is
if they apologize that's all they have
to do apologize for those that drink
beer and uh for those that drink a lot
of it cuz Bud light's not you know I'm
basically trying to say like you know if
you're going to the bar with your
friends I'm I'm not going to I wouldn't
order Bud Light ever even before the boy
Yingling okay if if we're going to get a
beer it's going to be a Yingling maybe I
had one of those with Sheamus over the
last week it was nice they're great
Sheamus and uh and and you know if if
they if they only had like your
traditional Fair Blue Moon perhaps but
for those that you know drink a lot and
you've got something lighter would you
consider drinking Bud Light if they
issued a public stat let's say they
tweeted out a card and it just said we
are sincerely apologetic for having
sponsored Dylan mulany we understand it
was offensive we we deeply apologize to
those who are offended by it and we will
absolutely work to get your C your your
your you know your to bring customers
back would that be enough for you guys
one in the chat if yes two if you will
never drink Bud Light No Matter
What well I'll answer that no I would
not they want their young drinkers they
want to get their young drinkers they
want to get those young people hooked on
their drinks their alcohol drinks I'm
not into it but like apologizing for
having done that no not good enough i'
be like the Nazis apologized to get you
on their team before World War II was
over I don't think we can compare
budlight sponsoring Dylan M Hey Thomas
Jefferson said said that uh central
banks are more dangerous than standing
armies and a lot of this stuff is
Corporate looks like a mixed bag we got
both of those looks like people are it's
a mix between ones and two some people
are saying they're never going to drink
it again two is never going to drink it
again right yeah yeah
there's wow everyone's just basically
saying no never again of twos wow even
with an apology it's no good yeah but
you know the the chat here on YouTube it
is definitely uh it's it's got a
negative bent on it yeah it's got a
we're influencing it in real time got a
negative bent on it they're they
generally are kind of like no people
what did Luke say did you say Luke Luke
said he wasn't going to do it okay hold
on what if what if they apologize with a
video from James Lindsay which opens
with him saying uh uh him standing next
to to the CEO of inbev apologizing for
having sponsored Dylan mlan explicitly
saying they truly did not understand the
nature of gender ideology and these
far-left Fringe policies and how they
were affecting the business now that
they see how wrong it was they would
like to give the next 20 minutes of
their airtime to James Lindsay to
explain the problem of Marxism cultural
Marxism far-left gender ideology and
racial ideologies in our schools in our
universities in our politics take it
away James would you then buy a Bud
Light if the Super Bowl like Super Bowl
yeah I would because I know James
Lindsay would be like a complete jerk
for like the first five minutes he be so
Savage in that first five minutes on
that I'm trying to not swear too I was
just trying to come up with like what's
the antithesis of Dyan M like what is
the opposite of what you could do
probably that James Lindsay giving a
lecture on the problems of these woke
IDE it would the opposite like a real
woman
giving the opposite actual vagina Hab
just just like just like a a busty woman
being like we're so
sorry big hooters that had sex with real
man before you know very different
normally my my victory condition is if
they sell the company every's got the
one if they were to sell the anheiser
bush back to an American owner I'd then
I'd consider working buying from their
company again but I what you're saying
like if they did do that with James
Lindsay and they they did like a
campaign to educate people I'd be open
to that is inbev owned it's traded on
the stock market AB inbev yeah I think
it's a public if it's traded on the
stock market it's not really an American
or foreign company I mean who the owners
are the whoever owns the stock you know
yeah their headquarters is in Belgium
it's in laon Belgium um but they I mean
they sell that they sell things all over
the world they they stop being like
nowadays it is really true that there
are you know transnational you know comp
companies that actually transcend nation
and like Japanese car producers are a
huge example of that like Toyota ET all
this going be most our made Happy
technical Tuesday for those who
celebrate thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net